oh goodness
sorry only official photography only
official photography
please
which one
I know them
thank you
thank you
he will also be very happy
your excellencies
distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen a very warm welcome
to all of you in this beautiful location
here in Berlin and of course a very warm
welcome
to all of you joining us online my name
is aliaslan I'm an international TV
presenter moderator and journalist and
as your host today it is my great
pleasure and privilege to welcome you
all on behalf of our two co-hosts the
German G7 presidency and the European
commission to the international expert
conference on the recovery
reconstruction and modernization of
Ukraine
Russia's ongoing war against Ukraine as
causing immense human suffering and
destruction of critical
infrastructure
and it's apparent to everyone here in
this room that a major Global effort
will be required to rebuild Ukraine once
the war is over but that the process and
the planning for that has to start now
to that end today's high level
conference will bring together
world-renowned International experts
from International organizations
National governments think tanks and
academic institutions to discuss how to
shape the international recovery efforts
the idea for today's event was actually
initiated by the German G7 presidency
back in June at the G7 Summit in Elmo
and this conference clearly wants to
underline and reiterate that the
International Community stands United in
their support for Ukraine and its
Democratic future throughout the day
here on this very stage in numerous
panels and sessions will cover a wide
range of topics and I think we can all
look forward to stimulating debates here
on this stage a debate by the way which
you can all join by using the hashtag
recovery
of Ukraine and Now ladies and gentlemen
without further Ado let's give the floor
to our two co-hosts first up he is of
course the chancellor of the Federal
Republic of Germany a country that is
currently holding the presidency of the
G7 ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
German Chancellor Olaf Schultz
[Applause]
excellencies are not guests and
delegates friends in and from Ukraine
ladies and gentlemen
president from the line that I welcome
you to Berlin to support our Ukrainian
friends in realizing their vision for
their future
for the recovery reconstruction and
modernization of Ukraine for a peaceful
prosperous and resilient Ukraine with
whom we share a joint European future
as we speak Russia's vicious war of
aggression is once again intensifying
the latest in discriminate actor ethics
including the use of Kamikaze drones
against civilians and civilian
infrastructure in Ukraine Mark a new law
in Russian dismissible effort to wipe
Ukraine off the map
the apparent way of warfare only
demonstrates one thing
Putin's Russia is desperate
the proud and brave nation of Ukraine
will prevail
to ensure that it does prevail together
with all our friends and partners we
will resolutely continue to support
Ukraine politically financially in terms
of humanitarian assistance
and also with arms
for as long as it takes for as long as
that support is needed
in particular Germany will continue to
provide Ukraine with the air defense
systems it so urgently needs now
the best reconstruction is the
Reconstruction that does not have to
happen at all because Ukrainian cities
and power stations are protected from
Russian bombs drones and missiles
today
we do not yet know when this war will
end
but end it will
and when it does we will continue to
stand by Ukraine and its struggle for
security freedom and democracy
we know that no two countries history
are the same
but from our own historial historical
experience we also know that
reconstruction is always possible and
that it is never too soon to tackle this
task
now is the moment to convene the
brightest and best Minds to provide
expertise and recommendations to start
rebuilding Ukraine
now is the moment to use the world's
Collective knowledge to contribute to
Ukraine's future
now is the moment to develop the
institutional framework to govern and
deliver Ukraine's reconstruction
and now is the moment to discuss how
Ukraine's future can be built and
financed
that is why we gather here today to
discow how to ensure and how to sustain
the financing of the recovery
reconstruction and modernization of
Ukraine
for years and decades to come
so let me stress what this conference is
not it is not a regular donor conference
it is more fundamental than that
this conference is about
developing these structures and the
mechanisms that will help to facilitate
and finance
what John Maynard Keynes in 1944 called
permanent reconstruction
so that's what it is what is at stake
here nothing less than creating a new
Marshall plan for the 21st century a
generational task that must begin now
the recovery reconstruction of
modernization of Ukraine will indeed be
a challenge for Generations one that
will require the combined strength of
the entire International Community
but it is also
an opportunity for generations to come
if we get it right
so let us not just focus on
reconstructing what was as important as
this is at present
but let us also think about what can be
a more advanced sustainable and
resilient Ukraine
a Ukraine that will be an important
producer of green energy
an exporter of high-end industrial and
agricultural products
a digital Powerhouse with some of the
world's best I.T experts
an EU member with infrastructure and a
legal framework to match
for me
the European Union's commitment to
Ukraine as a future member is one of the
most consequential geopolitical
decisions of our times
our Global Endeavor to both reconstruct
Ukraine and pursue the EU assassin
process will yield enormous synergies
no not just Ukraine but Europe as a
whole will be the stronger for it
we also need to combine the various
International Trends in support of
Ukraine
during our presidency the G7 has taken
unprecedented steps to impose economic
costs on Russia and on those supporting
its war of aggression
based on the commitments we made for
Ukraine at the Irma Summit in June we
are now looking to our Japanese friends
as the incoming G7 presidency to ensure
the continuity of our support
T20 leaders will meet in Bali next month
and we encourage our Indonesian friends
to address Ukraine's needs as well as
the imperative to defend the
international rules-based order
the International Community established
a vision for Ukraine's future in Lugano
last July
I congratulate our Swiss and British
friends on the progress made and look
forward to the follow-up event next year
last but not least we come together here
in Berlin today as a global global
Community ready to pull our knowledge
and convene the expertise needed to
transform Ukraine
in its Fight For Freedom Independence
and sovereignty Ukraine is not alone nor
will it be alone
yet at this turning point in Ukrainian
history Ukrainian ownership and agency
are key
therefore I welcome president zelenski's
keynote speech and prime ministers
smigal's participation today
together we are looking forward to the
insights that the participating experts
bring to the table
we want to gather Pathways for financing
Ukraine's future not just for months but
for years to come
in order to be able to live up to this
gigantic Endeavor we need to develop
even better ways to bring together
public and private funders from around
the world to invest into a sustainable
future of Ukraine
we should discuss what a transparent
effective and inclusive governance
framework could look like one that all
our partners and the international
institutions present here today can
subscribe to
and we will hear from the very best
on aspects such as decentralization and
Regional development on anti-corruption
investment promotion and macro
Prudential practices
the better the setup we create for
Ukraine's reconstruction now
the more international support Ukraine
will enjoy in the years to come
in convening this excellent and diverse
International Group
we demonstrate once again our unwavering
support for Ukraine and our full
confidence that the values we all share
with Ukraine will prevail
thank you all for joining us for
thinking big and outside the box just at
the scale of the task ahead acquired
requires thank you very much
thanks a lot thank you very much to the
German Chancellor Olaf shorts for your
opening remarks for your leadership and
for initiating this conference that
we're all here together today I saw that
Ukrainian prime minister Dennis mihal
was listening very carefully to your
words warm welcome to you as well prime
minister we will see you later back here
on stage of course but this conference
has two co-hosts the German G7
presidency as well as the European
commission and therefore it is my great
pleasure now to welcome on stage the
president of the European commission
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
president uzula Fonda line
foreign
ministers excellencies ladies and
gentlemen distinguished friends of
Ukraine
we want to discuss the Reconstruction of
Ukraine today
thousands of destroyed houses
several hundred schools
turn to Rubble
count as Bridges roads power stations
Railway infrastructure
and Industry bumped
for ukrainians these are not just
statistics this is their everyday
experience
it's about having a roof over their
heads
a warm place in the winter
and classroom where their children are
safe
it's about going to work
bringing food home
and making a living
these are hard scary and painful days
for ukrainians
but ukrainians are showing us that they
have hope and confidence in the future
and they will keep fighting for it
and it is their future that brings us
here today
Europe has been supporting Ukraine from
day one on
we can never match
the sacrifices ukrainians are making
every day
but we can stand by their side
we have introduced the toughest
sanctions against Russia
overall the European Union member states
and European financial institutions
have provided Ukraine with more than 19
billion euros in assistance
and this is without military assistance
we are working hard to increase
Ukraine's access to our single Market
because this creates revenues for
Ukraine
and what is more
Europeans have opened their hearts and
their homes
to more than eight million ukrainians
who have fled Putin's bombs
and four million who asked for temporary
protection in Our member states
and I would like to thank the millions
of citizens
who are giving the most noble help to
their neighbors in need this is Europe
at its best
today we want to discuss how to step up
our ongoing support for ukrainians and
how to make the Reconstruction of their
beautiful country a resounding success
for me three points are key
first we need to make sure that Ukraine
at all time gets the support it needs
from relief to Rehabilitation to
long-term construct reconstruction
second
we need the right architecture in place
to make support as Broad and as
inclusive as possible
and third
as Ukraine has achieved candidate status
to access the European Union
we need to firmly embed Ukraine's
reconstruction efforts as part of its
path towards the European Union
so let us have a look at the first point
and that is Ukraine needs relief
fast Rehabilitation and reconstruction
we leave for the daily survival
to be able to pay the bare minimum every
single day
salaries for military and security
forces
salaries for teachers and doctors in the
hospitals and in the countryside
pensions for the pensioners and other
indispensable payments
according to the international financial
institutions and Ukraine
there's a need of three to five billion
euros a month
just to cover these recurrent running
costs
here
reliable support is needed from the
European Union from our friends in the
United States and of course from the
international financial institutions
I believe it's only right if the
European Union assumes its fair share
and I'm working with our member states
that the union could support Ukraine
with up to 1.5 billion euros every month
of the war which would be in some round
about 18 billion euros in 2023.
in parallel
Ukraine Ukraine needs fast
Rehabilitation right now as we speak
especially as Russia's deliberately
leading targeted attacks on civilian
infrastructure with a very clear aim to
get off men women and children of water
electricity and heating as the winter is
approaching
these are pure acts of Terror and Russia
tries to paralyze Ukraine but we will
not let this happen
and in addition
[Applause]
and in addition we know that there are
around 11 million internally displaced
people in Ukraine and they need shelter
heating water and electricity their
children need to go to school and
therefore we need to repair houses
schools and infrastructure already right
now
as European commission we have announced
to support this Rehabilitation of
damaged Ukrainian schools or the repair
of electricity infrastructure
and through the Union Civil protection
mechanism we have provided tens and over
600 000 items for shelter but we all
know more has to be done
this phase
of fast Rehabilitation is essential to
ensure that life can continue in Ukraine
and this brings me to our overall
important topic of today and that is the
Reconstruction effort
the Lugano reconstruction conference
representatives from more than 40
countries and international organization
agreed on the so-called Lugano
principles
Ukraine owned
reform focused
transparency accountability and rule of
law
Democratic participation
gender equality and inclusion and
sustainability
I think these are very good principles
but now we have to fill them with life
and for doing that we need the best and
the brightest on reconstruction that's
why we have invited you
now it is time to bring the platform to
action together with the international
donors International businesses business
and of course Civil Society
we have no time to waste
the scale of Destruction is staggering
the World Bank puts the costs of the
damage at 350 billion euros
this is for sure more than one country
or one Union can provide a loan we need
all hands on deck
the G7 the European Union Europe strong
Partners like the United States Canada
Japan the UK South Korea Australia New
Zealand and many many more
and of course
we need the expertise of our partners
from the European Investment Bank the
ebrd to the World Bank and the IMF
so we will discuss today
how to involve these sectors and actors
how to map investment needs
how to coordinate action and of course
how to channel the resources in a
reliable and accountable way
the coordination platform
that the International Community has
been discussing in the past month
needs to take off ground as soon as
possible preferable before the end of
the year or early at the beginning of
next year
We Stand ready
to offer the European Commission
to provide the Secretariat to the
platform
we want the work to start and to be done
and that leads me to my final point
Ukraine will be in the lead I think this
is Paramount
because our action
will be driven by the aspirations and
the desires of the Ukrainian people
and Ukraine has a very clear vision and
decided to become member of the European
Union
Ukraine has achieved candidate status
and with the ongoing relief and
Rehabilitation
Ukraine will combine investment and
reforms with the AIM to become a vibrant
part of Europe's sustainable and digital
future
with the law and institutions in place
to uphold the rule of law to fight
corruption and to have good governance
standards of all partner countries and
our European Union
because the road to reconstruction is at
the same time Ukraine's path towards its
vision
it is a strong anchor to become a modern
and prosperous country
and ladies and gentlemen
for all this we need you we need you and
your expertise your insights that are
key for us to succeed
this is why I'm especially looking
forward to this conference today
from the bottom of my heart I thank you
for being here with us every Euro every
dollar every pound every Yen we spent
is an investment in Ukraine but it is
also an investment in the Democratic
Values around the globe
and all this is urgently needed
but it is also a statement if we are
successful with that it is a statement
that the free and democratic nations of
this world stand together and that we
stand up for our values and the
courageous Ukrainian men and women are
fighting for their independence but they
are also fighting for the international
rules-based orders and we will stand by
their side as long as it takes Slava
ukrainia Long Live Europe
thank you
welcome back to Berlin and thank you
very much for your remarks president of
the European Commission
Ursula Fonda line you said very
poignantly that Ukraine is in the lead
here this conference is of course hosted
co-hosted by Germany and the European
commission but Ukraine is in the lead
this is all this conference this whole
process is being coordinated very
closely with the Ukrainian government
that goes without saying and therefore
I'm extremely delighted that we're
joined live from Kiev by a gentleman who
in many ways has become the embodiment
who personifies the courage and
resilience of the Ukrainian people of
his people and he's joining us live now
from Kiev ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome the Ukrainian president
zielinski
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
Mr President hello from Berlin to Kiev
it's wonderful to have you with us I
hope you can here as well we're very
much looking forward to your remarks
foreign
foreign
currency
is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
Universal
foreign
foreign
creative
results
potential
numbers
foreign
[Music]
foreign
which is
foreign
foreign
this is sometimes
yes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much president zielinski
for your works the goal is to move from
abstract numbers to concrete goals
your leadership style is admired all
around the world we wish you nothing but
the best may this war end very soon
thank you so much for joining us live
from Kiev once again this is your
applause thank you so much
[Applause]
and this concludes the opening remarks
for this very important conference Now
we move to the opening plenary titled
International perspectives on Ukraine's
recovery reconstruction and
modernization the most recent U.N vote
has clearly demonstrated that the
predominant majority of the
International Community stands with
Ukraine so in our opening plenary we
therefore want to zoom in on the
international perspectives on Ukraine's
recovery reconstruction and
modernization first up as a speaker he
is of course the prime minister of
Ukraine and we welcome him to Berlin
prime minister Dennis mihalis here
ladies and gentlemen
president it's good to have you with us
he is the president of the Swiss
Confederation welcome to Berlin Ignacio
Cassis is here ladies and gentlemen
welcome Mr President it's good to have
you with us a country that is playing a
pivotal role in this conflict first and
foremost by lending support and taking
in a large number of Ukrainian refugees
he's the prime minister of Poland and
we're delighted he's here prime minister
Mateos here ladies and gentlemen
it's good to have you prime minister
welcome to Berlin and of course
International organizations play a key
role in ensuring that this efforts are
taking the right path on the recovery
reconstruction modernization angle
therefore it's my great pleasure to
welcome now on stage the Secretary
General of the oecd Matthias Corman
ladies and gentlemen
it's good to see you
and this first session will be moderated
uh by the president of the German
martial funds who formerly a U.S Deputy
assistant Secretary of State in the
Bureau of European and Eurasian Affairs
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Heather Conley
thank you
and with that Heather great to have you
with us and with that happy to hand over
to you
it's great to have you
after the welcoming round of course
Heather
great to have you with us
dear guests Chancellor Schultz president
vonder lion excellencies uh thank you
Ali very much
policy makers from Warsaw to Ottawa
Washington to Madrid Brussels London and
Berlin just to name a few have all
wanted the same policy outcome we want
Ukraine to win
but what does winning yes
but what does winning mean for me
winning means Ukraine wins the largest
land war in Europe since the second
world war and restore its sovereignty
and territorial Integrity first to its
pre-february 24th borders and then to
its 1991 internationally recognized
borders through the provision of
military assistance
for me winning means ensuring that
Ukraine has sufficient macro economic
support to fund its military forces pay
salaries and survive economically as the
Russian military cripples civilian
infrastructure and limits the export of
grain shipments
and most importantly winning means the
modernization and full recovery of
Ukraine and we must understand that the
cost of winning this future is so much
less than the cost of failure
winning is not simply Ukraine's survival
winning means Ukraine thrives as a
modern prosperous and secure country
this is our most pop powerful policy
response to Vladimir Putin and as
president zielinski said this vision of
this hopeful future is what the Kremlin
wishes to destroy it is why it's
intensifying its attacks most recently
with Iranian and drones and ballistic
missiles it wants this donor conference
and the International Community and the
private sector to stop thinking planning
and rebuilding Ukraine don't let the
naysayers say we can't during the
darkest days of the second world war
allies were Planning and Building the
post-war environment they stayed focused
on winning and planning a more peaceful
and secure world we must build that
Vision in the 21st century and if the
Marshall Plan taught us anything is that
the West builds and rebuilds if
necessary because democracies build
because we must deliver hope for our
citizens that there will be a better
tomorrow and of course this means we
need a modern Marshall Plan for Ukraine
this of course is music to my ears as
president of the German Marshall fund an
organization born out of gratitude by
the German government and people to the
American people for the transformative
effect of the Marshall Plan I wonder Mr
Prime Minister if 25 years from now we
will have a Ukrainian Marshall fund for
of the of Europe that is a hope I hope
to see someday thank you
thank you this is indeed the task of Our
Generation and the Marshall Plan gives
us a Hopeful Road map we know from the
original Marshall Plan that Ukraine must
lead its own recovery our challenge
today just as it was in 1947 is that
there needs to be a Continuum from the
emergency needs to long-term recovery
one cannot exist without the other we
know today's donor conference must
address both elements and all Western
assistance must be rooted in Ukraine's
integration into euro-atlantic
institutions we know Ukrainian civil
society and cities as well as the
principles of transparency and
accountability also must be deeply
rooted in Ukraine's restriction
reconstruction we know we need a highly
effective International coordination
mechanism something I hope we can agree
to today and we know we need a mechanism
that will put Russian assets to work to
rebuild Ukraine and most importantly we
know that a Marshall plan for you
Ukraine just as the original plan was in
1947 will deliver hope for as long as it
takes and with that in mind and with
that framing let's turn the podium over
to uh to the colleague who will lead
this recovery please uh join me with
your applause in welcoming prime
minister dushima to of Ukraine to the
podium thank you Mr Prime Minister
Dear Mr Federal Chancellor
you know all of their Madam president of
European commissioner Ursula dear
friends colleagues excellencies
distinguished guests of this conference
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen
this is Oksana and in October
10th she look she took her son to
kindergarten and went to work at the
hospital Oksana saved children from
oncology a Russian missile killed Oksana
in the center of Kiev in the middle of
the street now we will see the video and
there will be these pictures actually it
is she Oksana
and this is her family
and she was
Doctrine oncologist
and it's actually what happens in the
middle of October in the middle of
center of cave and this is Victoria
Victoria was soon to become a mother on
October 17th an Iranian drone killed
Victoria her husband and there unborn
child Russia destroyed a life that did
not even have time to be born
this is 11 year older term a Russian
Missile hit his house our time late
under the rubble of the house for six
hours rescues and doctors
fought for him but the Russian missile
did not give him a chance
this is the life that ukrainians live
today
only in October the terrorist Country
released more than 300 missiles and
drones
which were supposed to explode
burn
Ordinary People destroy their houses
playgrounds streets if I woke up it
means I was lucky enough not to be
killed by a Russian rocket
every Ukrainian wakes up and goes to bed
with these words for eight months Russia
had brought great pain tears destruction
and death to our land
sometimes it even seems that the world
has started to get a used to it
getting used to those things that a year
ago they could not even imagine experts
need to form the reconstruction plan and
how many decades to implement it I know
that together with you we do not just a
lot
but sometimes an incredible amount we
are moving not just a fast but at a
speed which was impossible just a couple
of years ago we do everything possible
and sometimes the impossible
and for that we sincerely thank each and
every one of you
but we have to work even better and
faster we have to respond more quickly
to be to the challenge that are
presented to us every day every hour the
purpose of today's event is an X is an
expert conference its results should be
through calculations of exactly how
Ukraine should be rebuilt step by step
it's very important to calculate
everything correctly but it is no less
important to start restoring everything
that the aggressor destroyed today we
are doing everything we can more than 60
percent of our budget goes to defense 16
to social programs 13 to medicine and
education at the same time we were able
to allocate almost 125 Millions Euro for
a rapid recovery this is this will be
enough for only five percent of damaged
objects
that's why we need your help I know that
in some circles idea is wondering first
and the war and then we will talk about
recovery you may ask why we need to
restore heating plants
if tomorrow they can be destroyed again
because people should live not freeze
you may ask why we need to rebuild
damaged Enterprises if a missile can fly
there again because people have to work
you may ask why we need to restore
Bridges roads and hospitals and today
Madam president of European commission
answered this question because people
need place where to treat and curse with
humanitarian Aid with your humanitarian
Aid reach to those who are in need
recovery right now and the development
of recovery plan are not contradictory
but complementary we have to work in
both these directions in lugana We
approved the principles on which
Ukrainian recovery should be based and
we do our homework
for example Ukraine will lead the
recovery process and implement it
together with all International partners
our joint reforms delivery office has
collected comments and proposals for the
draft recovery plan for from
representatives of 14 countries un U.N
agencies the representations of the
European Union in Ukraine the European
bank for reconstruction and development
the World Bank group the European
Investment Bank the Japanese
International
cooperation agency a number of
international organizations and
institutions the organizations for
economic cooperation and development
carried out through examination of the
draft recovery plan
our government received more than 300
proposals from
163 representative of business and ngos
in Ukraine they have been worked out by
working groups and appropriate changes
have been made to the sections of the
plan and still it's flexible to any
changes we fulfill our obligations
another example Ukraine will continue
rapid reforms since June of this year we
have been a candidate for EU memberships
since October an oecd prospective member
country this membership perspective is a
powerful intensive for reforms we are
transforming every day
we continue to implement the association
agreement
by the end of the 2022 we plan to adopt
about 100 EU standards for various
Industries business deregulation
privatization systemic Customs reform
government reform increasing the
targeting of assistance to Citizens and
businesses liberalization of the labor
code
digitalization and expansion of
Electronic Services all these things
happen against the backdrop of War
despite all this we fulfill our
obligations
let's go further transparency and
accountability in lugana all of us say
that hundreds of billions of the US
dollars are needed to restore Ukraine
some said that these are unrealistic
amount
therefore the government of Ukraine
together with a team of the World Bank
and the European commission presented a
report on the damage caused by the war
as of June of this year the verified
needs for Recovery already amount to 350
billion US Dollars the World Bank
reports is transparent and accessible to
everyone
Ukraine has already adopted the
necessary legislation for the creation
of their fund for liquidation of the
consequences of Russia's aggression
within the framework of the state budget
of Ukraine and today president of
cricket of Ukraine announced creation of
fund of state fund for Recovery of our
country
spending funds from the budget both
Ukrainian and any any other
civilized country is more than a public
and transparent process it is not
possible to hide anything all donors
know and see the direction of
distribution of the donated funds each
of their directions is a separate
agreement it is signed by members of the
government of Ukraine funding the
directions and clearly indicated there
we fulfill our obligations
there are many such examples I think
that within the framework of this
conference you will hear in more detail
about all of our developments we do our
job we adhere to all
to all principles
but it is time to move on and to
implementation of the plan according to
to their DNA report verified by the
World Bank we need 17 billion for rapid
recovery president of Ukraine mentioned
today this amount
this estimate does not take into account
the losses from the updated tactics of
the Russian switch goal is to create a
humanitarian catastrophe by destroying
the infrastructure for the supply of
electricity drinking water
and heat on the eve of winter
the genocide of ukrainians and the
migration tsunami in the EU are Russia's
new plants
one of the lugana principles is united
in defense United in recovery
thus our task is to quickly and
effectively respond to new challenges as
quickly as and effectively we repo
respond to military treats
streets within the framework of the
Ramstein group that is why the
government of Ukraine wants to invite
all Partners to start Financial
coordination platform
and meetings under the co-chairmanship
of the USA
the European Union and Ukraine we have
to regularly hold meetings on the
minister Ministers of Finance level of
j7 countries and other partners leaders
of the International Financial
organizations including World Bank IMF
ebrd
eib and oecd the purpose of these
meetings is to coordinate financial
assistance to Ukraine determine
directions for priority and long-term
recovery
as well as sources of their financing
we need to coordinate funding approaches
and consider military Risk insurance
options
and in the end to find a solution how to
most effectively confiscate or use the
Frozen Russian assets for the recovery
of Ukraine in addition these meetings
will provide an opportunity to develop
policies and principles that will become
Universal mechanisms for the recovery of
any country that suffered aggression and
will form plan for stating of the EU
around the recovery plan of Ukraine
finally I would like to thank Germany
and Chancellor Schultz
for organizing this event and for the
unchanging and principled position of
solidarity with Ukraine
thanks to the president of European
commission Madame Ursula vanderline and
president
and for her president initiatives and
very stable support which you provide
for my country from finances and weapons
to already eight packages of sanctions
which help us to win this war
our gratitude to the oecd Secretary
General Mr Coleman for all his efforts
in favor of Ukraine
I would also like
to express special thanks to our friends
from Poland from Switzerland
from USA from Eastern Europe and Baltic
countries who have provided us with an
unprecedented level of assistance over
eight months thank you so much for this
we are grateful to all of the countries
and organizations that are now back to
back with us in our struggle for our
freedom and Independence we believe that
our Victory will be beginning of a
renewed and stronger Europe as well as a
better world thank you for supporting
Ukraine slavo crane thank you so much
Mr Prime Minister thank you very much
for those comments I welcome president
Cassis to to the podium uh the Lugano
conference in July set the tone and the
pace for this conversation and the
London Conference next year so Mr
President we welcome your comments thank
you
foreign
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
I'm very happy to be here with you in
Berlin in a safe and warm place
I would first like to thank the G7
presidency and the European commission
for organizing this conference many
thanks also to you personally commission
president from The Lion for your
commitment which has not diminished
since Lugano
and thank you to you Chancellor Schultz
for your commitment to the Ukraine
recovery process and for the warm
welcome this morning
ladies and gentlemen
I was in Kiev last week
where I met many very brave people
we all own them our deepest respect
for months they have been you have been
working day and night to defend
themselves against Russian segregation
and to regain the territorial Integrity
of their country
I'm speaking of president
Vladimir celinsky of prime minister
Dennis schmiehal whom I greet warmly
today their teams local authorities
Civil Society representatives and all
ukrainians whose lives are getting
tougher by the day
I was extremely impressed and moved
by the result and strengths of the
people despite the man-made humanitarian
disaster that is unfolding here in
Europe before our very eyes in the 21st
century and with winter fast approaching
during my visit to Kiev last week three
things struck me
first of all hope
beyond the urgent need for humanitarian
assistance to get through the winter the
Ukrainian people also need medium and
long-term perspectives
even if we are unfortunately unable to
predict when the war will end it would
be unforgivable not to move forwards
resolutely with the political process of
reconstruction
the people of Ukraine just like the many
refugees from Ukraine deserve a
perspective that offers hope
secondly clarity
my discussions in Ukraine showed that
many aspects of the recovery process
still need to be clarified
what form will International
coordination take
what governance structure will drive the
process
what funding sources are available and
which financial mechanism do we have at
hand
to mention just a few many of these
pending issues require quick precise and
firm answers if our ambition is to put
in place an unprecedented International
reconstruction process program a master
plan for Ukraine
the European Union is of course well
placed to play a prominent role in view
of Ukraine's aspiration to join but all
parties are called upon to join forces
for an effective recovery process
perhaps even the European political
Community which met the first time in
Prague on the 6th of October can also
play a supportive role I met with
Moldova president Maya Sando last Friday
and the shorter our support in
organizing an event that could be that
could very well be dedicated to
exploring this issue but of course I'm
also thinking of extra European States
and multilateral organization
third element trust trust is a central
element of the process trust between
Ukraine and its International Partners
but also trust between Ukrainian
citizens and their authorities
in the summer Ukraine and Switzerland
brought together all actors for an
initial gathering in Lugano
this was the first step towards a
structure at recovery process
the cornerstones of this political
process were set out in the Lugano
declaration the seven Lugano principles
which you can see on the screen behind
me are intended to assist and guide our
efforts
as a doctor I believe that actions need
to be evidence-based it is crucial that
the process of reconstruction be based
on a structured approach inspired by the
lessons of the past and backed up and
backed up by solid data
in view of the country's size and
precisely because the needs are so
immense setting the right priorities is
key
so beyond the Urgent and indispensable
need for humanitarian assistance their
needs
to be a proper needs assessment a state
in Lugano declaration Ukraine and its
people have to lead
this requires a domestic clarification
of the roles and responsibilities of
State bodies such as the parliament
regional and local authorities and
Ukraine's vibrant Civil Society
last Thursday in Kiev I was able to meet
a group of motivated and skilled young
people
they represented different organizations
including this year's Nobel Peace Prize
winners the center for civil liberties
I was impressed by how committed they
are to their country and how eagerly
they want to participate in the
government's reconstructions efforts
setting in motion on an inclusive
domestic process is a huge challenge
that requires Trust
the same trust that the International
Community needs in order to participate
in financing the process
we must be effective and efficient out
of a sense of Duty to the people of
Ukraine but also to be accountable to to
our own citizens who make these funds
available directly or indirectly through
International institutions we must not
fail
various actors such as the World Bank
the aeb ebrd and the oecd represented
here by Secretary General recordman have
produced excellent analysis and reports
two days expert conference is another
important step it allows up us to share
the knowledge gained and to deepen it
ladies and gentlemen
Switzerland remains a Dependable partner
we are focusing on efforts on those
areas where our added value is the
biggest and where our expertise is most
useful
as a neutral country we do not supply
weapons
but our legal obligation is in respect
of neutrality
do not in any way imply indifference to
the violent violation of international
law and to those values we defend such
as freedom and the right of people to
live under a peaceful and just
International order
my country stands firmly on the side of
international law and recognizes the
deterritorial integrity and National
sovereignty of Ukraine
I expect today's conference to make a
concrete contribution to defining a
successful deconstruction process for
this we need to draw on solid evidence
and lessons from the past I'm confident
that today's discussion will be fruitful
let's get to work Switzerland has rolled
up its leaves and is firmly on board you
can count on us thank you
[Applause]
this Mr President thank you so much for
underscoring the power of Hope the
importance of trust and the need for
Ukraine to lead its recovery speaking of
leadership I am delighted to welcome
polish prime minister
morivsky up to the podium to provide the
the leadership that Poland has provided
not only in security but also in
humanitarian support to the many who are
displaced from this conflict Mr Prime
Minister the floor is yours
thank you very much
dear president of the European Union
Chancellor
prime minister Excellence is ladies and
gentlemen
one Persona very well known in German
and German history
once said that
the war is a continuation of politics by
other means
and I think that Vladimir Putin
understood his words very very well
and when we speak of War we usually mean
armed conflict Battlefield what is going
on in Ukraine and that's that's correct
but these other means are also very very
important and the war in Ukraine is not
only the battlefield the cruelties which
were shown to us yet again by Dennis
a minute ago but also other fields which
we sometimes forget about like
cyberspace like Russian propaganda and
uh fake news or
on the field of economy
put in tailors his Battle Tactics to the
opponent in question he could not
conquer Europe militally if he didn't
first defeat it economically
so today Ukraine is fighting for its
independence and the protection of our
borders and our security as well
but the real struggle for European
sovereignty is also taking place
Elsewhere on this economic and
natural resources related Battlefield
we often talk about Europe's dependence
on Russian raw materials and indeed
Russia has behaved like a drug dealer
drug dealer who gives his first dose for
free because
he knows that the addict will come later
on
and will pay very dearly for next doses
today it is not enough to talk about the
Reconstruction of Ukraine and
reconstruction of you of Europe it's
it's more than that we have to talk
about reshaping of Europe and European
policies like energy policy and climate
policy as well
I remember in the 80 in in the early 90s
Bill Clinton once said it's the the
economy stupid it was the time when we
all believed that money will solve all
the issues and we it's enough to focus
exclusively on economy now that struggle
in Ukraine there but the Battle For
Freedom in Ukraine
has awakened all of us to to the other
perspective geopolitical perspective
the situation in Ukraine has awakened
all of us from this geopolitical slumber
in a perfect Market the cheapest
Solutions are usually chosen but perfect
markets are are usually only in outdated
economic textbooks in real markets the
cheapest solution often comes with
hidden price
and
cooperation between Europe and Russia
seemed cheap and effective until Putin
built it accordingly
it was supposed to be only gas contracts
but it turned out that Europe signed a
pact for its very soul
from a Russian point of view Vladimir
Putin made a mistake in my in my opinion
when he attacked Ukraine from the
Russian point of view I I emphasized
this because I'm sure
he would have won the war against Europe
or he could have had higher chances to
win the war against Europe
had he first continued to make it more
dependent to make Europe more dependent
the heroic struggle of the Ukrainian
people has not only saved Ukraine itself
but it has also
awakened many countries from our
geopolitical Slumber or from their
geopolitical slumber
for at least two reasons Ukraine should
be supported militally and financially
and and please bear in mind also this
second component I speak about this very
very often with
um with Dennis and with President
zawinski financial support indeed as
president for the Funderland emphasized
is critically important not only for the
next couple of months but also for the
entire 2023 to show the that we are
determined enough to support
um to support Ukraine therefore I I'm
gonna think
urzula but also crystallina who is with
us and and Werner and the other
institutions so eib international
monetary fund and other International
institutions who are aware of this that
we have to collectively gather three to
five billion euros per month to give
hope for Ukraine that they are not going
to be left alone
secondly the struggle the fight in
Ukraine is important because it's
supporting Ukraine is the best guarantee
for our own security and for securing
peace for for decades to come
anyone who does not support Ukraine
today has either betrayed our values
values of our civilization or is fooled
by Russia or sometimes both
or sometimes it's the Russian propaganda
of course which is so successful as I
indicated in at the beginning
victory in the fight against Russia is
closer not only thanks to the series of
military successes of the Ukrainian Army
not only because the Russian bear
is tired of sanctions and sanctions
packages are beginning to work more and
more effectively but also because of the
lot of large part of western world
has shown determination and tenacity
and in order to win the war against
Russia we must build completely new
security architecture as well in the
political and economic dimension
first the economic reconstruction of
Ukraine is crucial condition for
Europe's safety
Ukraine is our stronghold today and
investment
in strengthening it's it is our duty in
a moral sense
and in terms of real heart real politics
of of real and uh real hard and real
politics
at the same time reconstruction must
means must mean transformation
we must be guided by the principle
build back better
secondly we must make sure that the
offender pays for reconstruction Russia
should pay Ukraine war damages War
operations too many times over the
course of history we saw
uh the the aggressors
avoided consequences avoided
responsibility and it was not mentioned
today so I I'm going to emphasize that
there is a huge pot of gold to be taken
and dedicated for Ukraine's
reconstruction which is Russian assets
assets of Russia Federation and Russian
oligarchs they are frozen
in Switzerland and in many other
countries so all over Europe and the
globe but freezing means really not too
much frozen assets can increase in value
in several years or in two years time
they have to be
confiscated
and the money should be dedicated for
reconstruction of Ukraine thirdly we
must vigorously carry on working on the
process of Ukraine's integration in the
EU this is critically important
for peace has its price so it's time to
stop deluding ourselves that we will
remain safe without investing in defense
Poland is dedicating three percentage
points of igdp on defense and we are
going to increase this amount of money
even further
and six it is time for the fifth point
is the time for a great reorientation of
energy policy that's probably for
another conference but I'm going to
Signal this as well
the truth is we have no choice either we
make the effort that Independence
requires or we will pay for Freedom with
blood
when it comes to Military Support Poland
is proportionately the second largest
donor of the Ukrainian Army we allocated
almost one percentage point of our GDP
to support Ukraine financially
humanitarian help and from the point of
Military Support weapon devil delivery
so
let me conclude with some final remarks
the policy of appeasing Russia is
bankrupt and everyone who is still who
is still trying trying to enact it drags
Europe down
there are no errors then that cannot be
repaired
when I hear
Madame founder lion say that our
government Poland was right about Russia
and Ukraine I feel a sense of
satisfaction but I would forego I do I
would forego any sense of a feeling of
satisfaction for the European impetus to
act this is critically critically
important Europe is much stronger than
Russia but the fact that it has not been
able to stop putting yet only proves
that it is to some extent or it was a
paper tiger we have to strengthen lots
of our policies to really overwhelm the
difficulties which we are confronted
with
if we do not win the war with Russia we
risk more than just losing Ukraine and
its security we risk marginalizing the
entire continent the world only deals
with strong players Europe must prove
its strength it is our to be or not to
be moment thank you very much
Mr Prime Minister thank you very much
and let me very quickly as time is
moving on a welcome Matthias Corman
Secretary General of the oecd the oecda
precursor of a founding institution of
the Marshall Plan so we're delighted
with your legacy Sarah Mr Corman the
floor is yours thank you very much for
president
Prime Ministers Mr President
distinguished guest friends of Ukraine
all our most immediate focus in support
of Ukraine rightly and necessarily of
course reminds on securing a just peace
for Ukraine as soon as possible on new
crime's immediate financial needs and
macro Financial stability and indeed on
keeping the lights on keeping the
heating going and the water flowing
keeping the other basic Services going
in Ukraine throughout this war which we
of course all continue to like for
granted but of course it is right that
we must plan and prepare for recovery
and reconstruction now and importantly
we must Ensure
we combine reconstruction efforts with
the necessary reforms to help modernize
Ukraine
we all want to help
we all want to support the emergence of
a better stronger more modern Ukraine
operating consistent with the high
standards expected from a prospective
member country of the European Union and
the oecd
to achieve this
we will need a better coordinated
and more coherent International approach
with the EU the G7 the IMF the World
Bank group the multilateral development
Banks and all relevant International
organizations working together in a
well-structured inclusive platform for
policy and donor coordination
so I warmly welcome the cause of
Chancellor Schultz and president
fonderline and prime minister shmiha to
put the right inclusive governance
architecture implies to support the
recovery reconstruction and
modernization effort
we also need a clear division of labor
which reflects each partner's core
strengths
at the oecd we've been working in
partnership with Ukraine since 1991.
a partnership which was reinforced and
further strengthened at two key
occasions
first in 2014 and again following
Russia's illegal invasion in February
at the oecd we have stood and we
continue to stand in strong solidarity
with Ukraine and we stand ready to do
everything we can to help Ukraine
rebuild better
since the Lugano conference we have
formally welcomed Ukraine as a
prospective member of the oecd we have
commenced an initial accession dialogue
with the IM to lift Ukraine's adherence
to oecd standards and participation in
oecd bodies Ukraine has also formally
asked to join the oecd working group on
bribery in international business
transactions and to accede to the oecd
anti-bribery convention
as a first step towards adherence to the
anti-bribery convention we have
commenced the process for Ukraine to
join the working group as a participant
for an initial two-year period
we have previously contributed to the
establishment of key anti-corruption
institutions in Ukraine including the
National anti-corruption Bureau the
specialized anti-corruption prosecution
office and the high anti-corruption
court and we will continue to build on
that work together in close partnership
with the government of Ukraine
we have established a dedicated oecd
Ukraine liaison office to progress our
work on supporting Ukraine's reform and
modernization efforts which we hope to
physically open in Kiev as soon as
possible
over the summer we supported the
governor of Ukraine in the preparation
and review of the of its National
Recovery plan and we are revising and
aligning our joint oecd Ukraine action
plan with the priorities set out in the
government's recovery plan
we are working with the government on
immediate support for educational
continuity
for displaced children and young people
who are looking to the future with a
project on redesigning Ukraine's
education system and we're also ready to
support Ukraine on public governance
policies to create Level Playing Field
conditions for domestic and foreign
firms and investors in areas such as
competition
style and Enterprises reform the energy
sector and investment
we plan to undertake a formal oecd
economic survey of Ukraine in order to
help identify priority structural
reforms for macroeconomic stabilization
recovery and modernization
and we're also continuing our
long-standing work with Ukraine in
support of Ukraine's decentralization
efforts
pre-war surveys showed us that
ukrainians write it the work of the
country's new local authorities
positively and they have proven
resilient and very effective in Wartime
and we're continuing to work intensively
with Ukraine on tax reform as part of
the base erosion and profit shifting and
in training Ukrainian judges and on
fiscal rulings there's much to be done
as you can see to optimize the outcomes
we need to do it all together in a
well-coordinated and coherent why we are
looking forward to doing our bids and
Slava Ukraine
Mr Secretary General thank you so much
and now by video we finally welcome our
our last colleague UK foreign secretary
James cleverley has put forward a video
from legano to the London conference
this is the bookend of that so we'll
play that video now and warmly welcome
secretary cleverly
Chancellor Schultz your excellencies
ladies and gentlemen when Putin launched
his Onslaught against Ukraine in
February he arrogantly assumed that he
would conquer his neighbor within a
matter of days but the people of Ukraine
fought back with Invincible courage
saving their capital from The Invader
and defeating Russian advances time and
time again
president zielinski stood up to be
counted ukrainians stood up to be
counted and freedom-loving democracies
around the world came to their aid
Putin's Imperial ambition to conquer his
neighbor amounts to the greatest
possible violation of the international
rules that protect Every Nation if his
aggression were to succeed every
expansionist Tyrant would be emboldened
to do their worst and no country would
be safe anywhere in the world
that's why we're all determined to stand
up with Ukraine's people until they win
and I have not the slightest doubt that
they will Britain is Ukraine's second
largest military donor after United
States committing 2.3 billion pounds
this year and we all provide the same
again in 2023. we've committed 220
million pounds in humanitarian
assistance since February and we've
welcomed over 100
000 Ukrainian refugees into our country
we've also made 1.3 billion pounds
available to Ukraine by underwriting
World Bank and ebrd lending and
providing 74 million pounds of direct
grants to Ukraine's government but we
all share a responsibility to help
Ukraine's people rebuild their country
after they achieve Victory we know the
Monumental scale of the task every day
The Invader is reducing more of Ukraine
to ruins destroying schools pulverizing
hospitals and Wrecking countless homes
as winter approaches Putin is
obliterating power stations and
depriving millions of ukrainians of heat
and light we must use this conference to
unite behind Ukraine's reconstruction
and development plan learning the
lessons from previous reconstructions
and using them to help rebuild Ukraine
and we must take forward that work at
the Ukraine recovery conference in
London next year International
cooperation has helped Ukraine's Heroes
to turn the tide on the battlefield and
it will be equally essential to help
Ukraine rebuild so that when Victory
comes Ukraine's people can Thrive and
prosper in the freedom that they have
fought and died to preserve
secretary cleverly thank you very very
much for those important words
and of and of course this conference is
an extremely important stop as we began
in Lugano and moved to London next year
ladies and gentlemen I stand between
your coffee break and a family photo so
I'm going to end this uh very quickly
but I think we've heard today we've
heard about Hope determination Victory
coordination Unity strength confidence
these are the words that will enable
Ukraine to modernize and fully recover
with your warm Applause please thank our
excellent panelists for their remarks
foreign
from left to right please please remain
seated for a second and follow
instructions please for a second remain
seated thank you so much prime minister
Prime Minister President
Secretary General thank you heather
indeed so before everyone gets moving
there's going to be a family photo now
outside only for the speakers of this
conference if you're not a speaker
please remain seated for just a second
and
foreign
[Music]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen
let me introduce to you our Podium for
this press conference the Ukrainian
prime minister Dennis schmihad
and the EU commission President we start
with three statements the first one by
the chancellor the second one by was La
Fonda line and then by Mr shmihal and
then we have time to three or four
questions
Mr Chancellor my name
is
become here in Berlin
Deutschland Europa the international
systems
conference
thank you
that's Mark said again
oil
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
organizations
the brighter International understood
some foreign
speakers
foreign
game
is organizations
platform
foreign
foreign
Europa
Minot Peril and put in blood
is
good morning this is foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh excellencies
Mr Federal Chancellor The Madame
President of European commission my dear
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
organization of this conference thank
you for this very fruitful negotiate
negotiations and thank you for your
unwavering and very stable and very
strong support of my country first of
all I would like to say the greatest
gratitude to Germany for military
support for sanctions support for
financial support Germany is the second
biggest donor in sense of grant money
for Ukraine after United States and we
appreciate this so much we're grateful
for this to you personally dear
Chancellor your Olive I also told to Mr
Chancellor that German Weaponry is
working perfectly on the battlefield and
Iris T is the best one system which
Ukrainian soldiers have now on the
battlefield it protects our life lives
our infrastructure and it works
perfectly I told yesterday that nine of
10 Rockets from irec reached the goal
and work even ideally we also use gear
parts we also use Mars 2 and other
equipment and ammunition and we
appreciate this so much we also
gratitude for financial support and
especially for organization of this
conference like a platform for
scientific and expert discussion how to
recover Ukraine how to
begin this process today which
priorities we should find where are the
sources how to use different sources of
finances for future recovery so this
conference is only beginning I think
that we will continue this kind of
meetings and we propose and now I will
say some words about European commission
and about personal engagement of Madame
President of European commission
jerusala thank you so much for your
really great support of Ukraine
tremendous support of my country and I I
will not repeat all these three big
Parts because as president of Ukraine
said we all are on the same page and we
could just change our speech our notes
for this press conference and thank you
that we all understand all the stages
how should we recover Ukraine but not
only Ukraine we all should be recovered
we all should be involved into the
recovery process because European Union
European countries also are suffering
because of this aggression from Russia's
side because of these hybrid methods and
I think that we should all together be
United in defense of Ukraine and
Democratic principles Freedom principles
and we should be United in recovery
because recovery it will be the biggest
project ever on Ukraine or on European
continent so I believe that we should
begin now because as I told during my
speech in this conference people need to
life not to freeze and we should recover
our infrastructure immediately we should
recover housing we also should count and
and to see how will we recover and
modernize not recover but build back
better is a next principle Logano and we
would like to modernize our economy
according to the European directives
according to the European rules and
standards because our way our path is
European path and we are a candidate
country and we would like to be a
full-scale member of European Union is
our big aim it's our goal
so thank you so much for your call
hosting of this conference and for your
efforts I believe that we will continue
and we have a preliminary agreement with
IMF with the seven countries with
European commissions that that we will
organize uh Financial coordination
platform I hope here in Germany uh not
later than end of this year such like
Financial Ramstein because Ramstein
format is very effective for military
cooperation and coordination and we need
have something like this in in sense of
finances and I hope that we will find
all the answers where are the sources
how should we ensure make Insurance of
War risks in Ukraine which are
priorities for financing how should we
participate in this financing Rich
methods and so on so and so on so I
think it will work I also would like to
touch very shortly
yesterday's Ukrainian German fifth
business forum and also to thank to you
Mr Chancellor for organization and
participation so big quantity of German
businesses which are strongly interested
to go to Ukraine and from this scene I
would like to say thank you to a German
business say to our great gratitude to
German business which continue to
operate in Ukraine to pay taxes into the
Ukrainian budget to save working places
and also I would like to gratitude to
German business and to European
businesses which leave Russian market
and don't pay money to this bloody
budget which Finance war in Ukraine so
it's crucially important
to understand that it's it's very very
uh very important for us for Ukraine so
I think that we will continue and this
conference will continue work today will
bring us very good uh basis results for
future recovery and for today's recovery
I will not repeat all the rest words
thank you so much thank you thank you
Finance yes come I'm inside here
foreign
yeah
and the conference organizations foreign
foreign
foreign
Suzanne
um
Christine
foreign
Promenade
resorts
foreign
foreign
[Music]
numbers and we do we also do our
homework and we decrease our budget
deficit next year till the three to four
billions per month because this year it
was higher than 5 billions per month we
decrease and cut all possible
expenditures in our budget but we still
need three to four billions per month
for financing of this budget of work
this is a price of work monthly price
and as president zelenski noted during
this conference 38 billions it's our
total budget deficit for the 2023.
unfortunately we have lost from 35 to 45
percent of our GDP of our economy during
this year and Russia continue
realize their terroristic stress
strategy and destroy our infrastructure
heating energy and so on so on you you
see this all and you understand this all
so we have the promises and we have hope
that the European commission and
European Parliament will support this
decision will
disburse for Ukraine 18 billions around
18 billion Euro for the next year for
monthly support of budget deficit we
also hope that United States will
support the same amount 1.5 billion per
month we also work with IMF and have
very fruitful negotiations with Madame
cristalina here during this conference
and day before so
we have hope that we will have a monthly
budget support but we also need as
president noted today 17 billions for
rapid recovery and as Madam president
noted we need this money to recover
infrastructure immediately it's a
wintering expenditures to help us
survive this winter to save the people
from humanitarian catastrophic and to
save the European continent from the
immigration wave from the immigration
tsunami I name it in sense of Weaponry
we have a very good relation now in
sense of Weaponry support in sense of
training of our soldiers with Germany
European commissions support us too and
we need more Weaponry we need more
ammunition to inward this war and we
will be very thankful and very grateful
if we will have additional Weaponry
additional ammunition we need thanks
from our partners from all of our
partners we need heavier Mort Vehicles
we need additional artillery units
hobbiters so these all are the aim of
negotiations in the Ramstein format and
I'm sure that we will reach all the
goals during this time and all together
will win the war thank you for your
question thank you next question right
here and the more questions one person
tells us the less persons can ask
questions that's a whole problem right
here second row now yeah
or he didn't then your neighbor sorry
okay nice thank you Natalia
um
foreign okay
um let me start to answer indeed our aim
is not only to freeze but to seize the
assets this is the aim this is uh what
the legal basis is concerned not trivial
so as you rightly said already we're
working on that we have created a task
force with all the experts also from our
member states and international experts
which is called season freeze task force
not only to map what is out there has
been frozen but also what are the legal
preconditions that have to be given to
be able to seize and use these assets
for example for the Reconstruction of
Ukraine So my answer is a mixed one uh
the wool is there but legally it is not
trivial there's a lot of work still in
it to reach that goal very important is
always to keep in mind we insist on the
rule of law and therefore we abide to
the rule of law and therefore this
process has to be legally sound
thank you for your question to be very
clear
it is a very difficult
legal question
and so a lot of work has to be done
all of us will have to go through these
questions what is feasible what is not
feasible if you are sticking to rule of
law and this is why the commission is
working hard to understand the problem
and to find an idea about how to act and
what to do but we are right at the
beginning of something that is
unprecedented so it will be not an
answer to be expected very very soon if
I get right from the commission and
there's good reason for this it's also
on the international level a very
similar question but this is even more
one of the reasons why this conference
is so important we have to take
responsibility all the countries of the
International Community
that are supporting Ukraine that are
organizing solidarity today with
financial humanitarian aid but also with
the support we give with weapons
I have to understand that recovery is a
task that will have consequences for all
of us in the world for a long long time
for decades and this is so crucial as I
said earlier in my speech but also in
the first answer to the request
it will be important that even in 15
years
the
Ukraine in recovery can rely on
Financial
structures that will support the
recovery for time afterwards and
understanding how this will go this is
the reason for this conference and we
are sticking to this very important
question
if you let me I will speak in Ukrainian
Services is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
leadership or rather for an American
leadership what's the best from the
European from the Ukrainian point of
view and the financial Ramstein you're
talking about do I understand that right
that that is something separate from the
platform from the Reconstruction
platform uh we are talking about here
thank you
conference organizations in
that's of stock and Democrats
and their operations foreign
foreign
foreign
future
um
does vita the oil pressure is
foreign
processor
yes
by the massive investiture
is
foreign
offset
thank you so I will continue in fact in
very naturally that one of the
principles of lugana conference is
united in defense United in recovery so
it's very important to have all on board
as Madam president said just now and
it's very important for us to have a
leading role of European commission and
European Union in process of recovery of
Ukraine again it's naturally because our
aim our goal is to be a member of
European Union so for us it's very
important to have on board United States
who is the biggest supporter of Ukraine
and sense of finances of Weaponry
politically for us it's very important
to have EU leadership role and
coordination role for us it's very
important to have Germany on board as as
I told second the biggest grant
grant donor for our country and weaponry
supporter and all countries which
support sanctions which support
financing of Ukraine during this time
should take take part in our recovery
process but recovery is very complicated
complicated issue and as Chancellor
explained it not for one year not for
two years it's for decades but we
understand that during the first years
we should realize a huge amount of
projects and it could be private
Investments it could be a support of
ifis International Financial
organizations it could be donations of
private persons it could be grants and
Loans of countries of unions it could be
funds of European Union so for all of
these instruments we will need different
infrastructural
approaches for investing of this money
into the recovery process but I'm sure
that during this process I name it the
biggest investment project on the
European continent ever many businesses
European businesses will go to Ukraine
and work with
projects on Ukrainian territory and we
need again infrastructure of insurance
of Works risks we need infrastructure
for
PPP projects and so on so on so it's
very very complex question and I hope
and I believe that during this
conference and during our next meeting
on the financial coordination platform
we will have answers how to create this
very complicated infrastructure of
future recovery process so I think that
this is actually what I would like to
add to my dear friends and colleagues
because it's very complex question thank
you so much we have time for one last
question
um and it's a lady under the yellow
jacket was uh signaling she wanted to
pose a question microphones coming
um Chancellor you said this morning that
it is important that the public and the
private sectors of all countries chip in
my question to all three of you is how
do you want to convince private
investors to go into a country where
their Investments are at risk of being
destroyed by Russian bombs will there be
some sort of an insurance scheme thank
you
thank you for your question
it's absolutely necessary that we
view to the European perspective of
Ukraine which is part of which is also a
good message for those who are going to
be investors today because they are
investing in a country that is following
this perspective it will be earlier or
later member of the European Union and
the second is that we are continuing
with our support we give to Ukraine in
this situation and as I said in my
speech we tried the best with especially
those arms deliveries we are giving as
Irish Jesus that was mentioned as the
flag tank
gephard to support Ukraine to save its
infrastructure and I think this is the
most important answer to the question
so there is an overwhelming willingness
to support
whatever meeting we have or in what with
whatever institution or business sector
we are speaking there is a clear
willingness because of the overarching
political importance of Ukraine to
prevail
um
it is also really notable that a lot is
already going on so this what we call
Rehabilitation right now help right now
is already happening for example the
Euro cities the Mayors are stepping in
with their Twin Cities and helping as
much as they can with all their local
expertise how to deal uh in a town
environment or how to deal in a city
environment what is the most necessary I
mentioned the school buses the 200 the
commission is giving but that's not
enough so the Euro cities are stepping
in and also recruiting school buses just
to help right now they are impressive
activities from ngos from Civil Society
from smaller communities who have
twinning communities in Ukraine to
support as much as they can so my
personal experience is that the
willingness is overwhelming even under
the very difficult situation
circumstances we have right now
so now we make the emphasize on the
development of small medium micro
business it's under less risks because
you can't destroy 1 million
entrepreneurs small medium micro
entrepreneurs by the one rocket but we
understand that the main volume of
volume of GDP the main reconstruction
programs will realize big Enterprises
big investors private investors State
investors and one of the main question
which will arise during our meetings is
actually Insurance of War risks in
Ukraine so we work with International
agencies we have negotiations with
States and now
Miga agency is prepared special program
for insurance of forests we work also
with Canada with Japan with all j7
countries with European commission to
create special programs for insurance of
War risks for their businesses on
Ukrainian territory and during the war
and immediately after water well
finished and we will win and then
businesses will go to Ukraine realize
all recovery projects earn their money
because this is one of the main factor
if business is interested to earn money
so they will go and they will take these
decisions so it's very important issue
thank you if you ask this question I'm
sure we'll find a way thank you ladies
and gentlemen this will conclude a press
conference because we have to clear the
room in order for the conference to
proceed I thank you for your interest
and say sorry to those who couldn't pose
a question bye-bye
thank you thank you
[Music]